مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
بعد ساعات من بدء الهدره الروسيه الاحاديه
اشتباكات المتقطعه في جبهات الحرب
الالكترونيه
جديده
مجله عالميه تختار العلا ضمن عجائب الدنيا
السبع للعام الجاريه 2023
في الرابعه ايضا
العراق تعود لاستضافه الاحداث الرياضيه
ساعات تفصلنا عن خليجي 25 في البصره
نبدا من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث
شابت عده اشتباكات متقطعه بدايه الهدنه
الروسيه وحاديه الجانب وفي هذا سياق اتهمت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اوكرانيا بقصف
المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره الشرقيه البلاد
مقابل التزام الجنود الروس بالهده وفق
الدفاع الروسيه رئاسه الاوكرانيه قالت من
جهه اين روسيا نفدت ضربات على كروماتوس
رغم وقفي اطلاق النار المعلن وفي هذا
السياق افادت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
بتواصل القصف المدفعيه الجمعه على جانبيه
الجبهه الاوكرانيه الروسيه في منطقه باخمه
قبل بدء سريان الهدنه اعلانات
166 قديفه على مقاطع
دون تسجيل
سابق حاله الانذار الجويه
في خمس مقاطعات تركي
ابو جهتي نفذ الجيش الروسي هجمات جديده
حيث افاد موقع كيفن ديبندنت بان القوات
روسيه استهدفت منازل مدنيين في منطقه
ثقيله وقال حاكم المنطقه ان عده منازل وخط
انابيب غاز وخط كهرباء والحق بها الضرر
جراء الاستهداف فيما لم ترد انباء عن وقوع
اي ضحايا في مدينه التي تسيطر عليها
اوكرانيه
وقد رصدت رويترز عوده الحياه الى طبيعتها
في مناطق السيطره الروسيه في دانياتك
تزامنا مع هدنه وقف اطلاق نار
[موسيقى]
مراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار رائد مرحبا بك
هل مازالت الخروقات لهذه الهدنه في حدود
الاشتباكات المتقطع
نعم خالد يعني هذه الهدنه بالفعل لم ترى
النور لكن اذا قارن ما بين القصد قبل
الدخول في هذه الهدنه القصف العنيف غير
المسبوق والمتبادل من الطرفين مقارنه
بالخلوقات التي تسجل اليوم اليوم الحديث
عن عشرات ال اييي اصابات او الضربات من
قبل الجيش الاوكراني كذلك المدفعيه
الروسيه التي تقصف من هنا لم نسمع تلك
الكثافه التي كنا نسمعها سابقه سابقا كما
اننا بالفعل نرى همم حرارات في الشارع
الناس فعلا يرتدون المحلات وينزلون الى
الاسواق ويزورون الكنائس همم احتفالا بهذا
العيد لابد ان اوكرانيا رغم انها همم لم
توافق على هذه الهدنه وهي كما اسلفت هي
عدنا من طرف واحد الا انهم ملتزمون نوعا
ما همم بتخفيض حجم القصف او يعني الهدوء
لماذا لا يعم المدينه رغم الضربات
المتقطعه والتي تصيب احياء ومدن في دانيت
فعلا خالد الموقف مريح نوعا مال الناس
هناك ارتياح في الشارع في منطقه دانيت لكن
اذا ذهبنا ابعد من ذلك اذا سمح الوقت لان
خالد للتحدث عن باقي وما يحدث في باقي موت
جيدا
همم
لكن هل ينطبق الان مر على مناطق التماس
الاخرى خصوصا في بخمه كمان يعني شورت
بالفعل ربما تختلف يعني مستوى المعارك
يختلف مستوى المعارك هنا في قلب المدينه
وعلى اطرافها عن ما يحدث على خطوط
المواجهه البعيده مثل الشمال المنطقه
وجنوبها حول مدينه اجلدار هناك فعلا ضربات
متبادله ما بين الطرفين بينما
بخصوص مدينه
من قبل الدفاع الروسيه وايضا من قبل
الدفاع الاوكرانيه حيث تشير ال ااه يعني
المعلومات الاوكرانيه الى ان الجيش الروسي
بدا ينسحب من تطبيق ذلك لشده مقاومه الجيش
الاخراني المصادر العسكريه هنا لدينا
ومصادر خاصه تشير الى تكثيف همم
الضخم العسكري بالعباد والجنود لمنطقه
شمال الادنيا حول وان هذا همم الضخ امتدا
ليصلها الى البلده المتاخمه لها من
الناحيه ال اا الشماليه باخ متقع شمال
المقاطعه خالد
ومتاخمه لها بلده صغيره تدعى سيدار في
الناحيه الشماليه
والقوات الروسيه القوات اتفاقنا الخاصه
من الناحيه الجنوبيه ومن الناحيه الشرقيه
وارادت ان تكمل الطوق لتشمل المنطقه
الجنوبيه لكن وجود منطقه سيلدار التي
يتمركز فيها ايضا جنود اوكرانيا جعل الجيش
الروسي يطوق بلده سيلدار مع باتمان ليكمل
الطوق الان اصبح الطوق على شكل هلال او
فكي كماشه ليدفع الجيش الاوكراني للانسحاب
من المناطق الغربيه هناك معارك شرسه ما
زالت قائمه همم ربما الوتيره ايضا هناك
اخف من سابقتها لان اوامر موسكو همم البدء
بالهدنه والرد فقط على القصف الاوكراني
يجعل همم حجم الضربات او كثافتها اقل من
ما سبق الهدنه طيب في في في هذا الوضع
الان هل من تحركات ملفته ايضا يمكن رصدها
على
مسار تعزيز ربما الوجود عاده التموضع في
مناطق او اخرى بالنسبه للطرفين رائد هل
هناك ما تم رصده
همم ما تم رصده هنا في المقاطعه دعني اشير
الى ما حدث في ااا نسمع اصوات القص طبعا
هذا دليل على ان القصد ما زال مستمرا همم
ما حدث في مدينه مكه يبقى خالد قبل ايام
ليله راس السنه الضربه الممتعه الكبيره من
قبل
القبورت الاوكرانيات لمركز تجنيد روسي
وكان سببه استخدام شبكات اتصال غير امنه
حسب الدفاع الروسيه والمحليه نشهد هنا في
مقاطعه همم كثافه عسكريه امام همم يعني
مراكز او نقاط توزيع الشبكات المحليه هناك
شبكات انترنت وتليفونات محليه همم تدعى
فينيكس وهذه الشبكه همم نجد افواج كبيره
من العسكريين امام لابد ان هناك خطب جديده
غير يعني اسلوب الاتصالات ما بين
المقاتلين ودولهم في هذه الفتره خاصه بعد
الضربه ايضا كانت عمليه ال ال
عده ايام كانت كبيره جدا وكما قالت الدفاع
الروسيه انها
مئات الجنود الاوكرانيين وعشرات الاليات
العسكريه وكذلك المقاتلات والطائرات
المسيره ذلك ما سبق الهدنه همم الان وقت
الهدنه لا نشهد الا خروج للمواطنين الى
الشوارع
ولو نسبه لكن الشوارع كانت خاويه كانت
ساكنه خالد اليوم نشهد هدوء رغم القذف
المتقطع ومازلنا نسمع اصوات القصيره الان
شكرا لك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار
روسيا التي اعلنت عن الهدنه ترى ان الموقف
الاوكرانيا
رهين امريكا حيث او رهن امريكا حيث قال
السفير الروسي في امريكا ان تولي انت نوف
ان واشنطن لا تريد تسويه سياسيه لصراع
الاوكراني متهمين الولايات المتحده
بالتخطيط لمسار خطير حسب قوله واعتبر ان
تنوب ان قرار البيت الابيض بتسليم مركبات
براد للقتاليه الى كيف خطوه تؤكد تجاهل
الولايات المتحده لعواقب خطيره محتمله
وعدم رغبتها في التوصل الى تسويه سياسيه
شر السفير وايضا الى ان الغرب بدا في
اضعاف روسيا عمدا تحت القياده الامريكيه
قبل وقت طويل من الحرب الاوكرانيه
ثانيا على نت وكاله وحرس الحدود البولنديه
ان عدد اللاجئين الاوكرانيين الذين
استقبلتهم البلاد
بلغا 800 ملايين و
1918,000
منذ بدايه العمليات العسكريه الروسيه على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه واضافت بان نحو 27,000
ومئه لاجئ ايضا وصلوا من اوكرانيا خلال
نهايه الاسبوع في ما غادر نحو 30,000 و200
شخص عائدين الى اوكرانيا ليبلغ اجماله
العائدين اكثر من سبعه ملايين شخص
ملحن جديد استشهدوا العلاقات السعوديه
الامريكيه خلال الفتره المقبله
ايضا عن مسؤولين امريكي
مع الرياضي لمواجهه تهديدات ايران في
العام الجاري 2023
الى بوادر على تحسين التعاون بين الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه في الاسابيع الاخيره من
انخفاض اسعار البنزين في الولايات المتحده
وانتهاء انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
في مشاريع عسكريه
واستخباراتيه جديده والجهود حساسه لاحتواء
ايران وسط جهود متعثره لاحياء الاتفاق
النووي الدوليه مع طارق
من مدينته يستن الامريكيه ينضم الينا
الباحث في الشونه الامريكيه احمد الحنطي
سيد احمد مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه
من خلال متابعتك هل هناك بوادر حقيقيه لما
ذهبت اليه الويل ستريت جورنال وهي ليست
الاولى ربما اكثر من صحيفه كانت تتحدث عن
مثل هذا التغير في الموقف الامريكي تجاه
العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
نعم هذا صحيح هناك عده تقارير ظهرت خلال
[موسيقى]
وحتى قبل بين فتره واخرى تظهر تقارير من
هذا النوع تاكد وجود مثل هذه التحركات
يعني ما يجب ان ننتبه لها ان العلاقات بين
السعوديه وامريكا هي علاقات مصالح
استراتيجيه مهما تدهورت هذه العلاقات هناك
احد عندنا لا تنخفض عنه ابدا لان كل
البلدين لديهما مصالح يحتاجها لتحقيقه
بالتعاون مع البنات الاخر لكن ما الذي
يمكن ان يدفع واشنطن اليوم الى اعاده هذه
العلاقه الى اقامه مشاريع عسكريه
واستراتيجيه واستخباراتيه ايضا جديده
وجهود حساسه بين قوسين كما جاء في في
صحيفه الوسطريت
يبدو ان يبدو ان الام يعني الامريكيين
بداوا يصلون الى قناعه انه لا يمكن احياء
التفاقه النوم قوي فبالتالي هم يحتاجون
الى زياده الضغط على ايران خلال الفتره ما
بعد الاتفاق النووي هذا الضغط يحتاج الى
تواجد يعني يحتاج الى تعزيز التعاون مع
الحلفاء امريكا في المنطقه بحيث تستطيع
امريكا
بالتعاون معه خلفاء الذين يريدون هذا
الشيء يعني هذا هدف مشترك الضغط على ايران
باستخدام العصا بدون وجود شجره الاتفاق
النوويه بهذه الحاله التي تحتاج ان
العصايه يكون اقوى اقوى طيب هل يمكن ايضا
اخذها من جاء اخرى كما يرى البعض من
المراقبين ربما بانه هذا للطمئنه المملكه
العربيه السعوديه الخليجيين في حال تم
توقيع الاتفاق النووي مثلا هل يمكن اخذوا
من هذه الزاويه
ما سمعناه قبل بدايه المفاوضات على
الاتفاق النووي ان الامر اصلا كل الاتفاق
هذا سيتم بالتنسيق مع دول المنطقه انهم
حتى لو لم يكونوا طرف مباشر في المفاوضات
فانه يتم التنسيق معهم على كل شيء
يعني همم قبل قبل تقديمها وقبل توقيعها
نحن يعني كمتابعين لا نعرف ان كان هذا
يحدث فعلا ام لا ولكن لا اظن ان الظن ان
تتم بهذا الشكل انا اعتقد ان اذا كانت
الهدف الطام انافه وهو سيتم بشكل اخر هذا
يدل على يعني لا نستطيع الجزم لكن انا
نمير الى انه فعلا الاتفاق في طريقه للموت
هناك مباشره على ذلك هذا ليس المؤشر
الوحيد لذلك هذا الاحتمال بالتالي كيف
يمكن النظر الى الطبيعه هذا التحرك وفق
همم هذا همم التوصيف يعني بان هناك مشاريع
عسكريه واستخباراتيه جديده وجهود حساسه ما
معنى حساسه هنا يعني
اعتقد ان هذه تعني نقل معدات عسكريه الى
مناطق يعني الى مناطق معينه هناك تقرير
سبق ان ظهر في الوورز قبل فتره طويله عن
نقل معدات عسكريه الى شمال غرب المملكه
العربيه السعوديه يعني وبناء قواعد ااه
اضافه الى انه يبدو ان هناك يعني الرفع في
التعاون الاستخبارات ضد ايران من معروف ان
هناك تعاون استخبارات ضد الارهاب بين يعني
غالبيه دول المنطقه ومنها السعوديه
وامريكا بس يبدو انه هناك زياده في هذه
الجهود نحن نعرف ان التعاون العسكري
والامني بين امريكا وبين السعوديه عالي
ومستمر ولكن يبدو انه سيتم فتح ملفات
جديده ضمن هذا التعاون يعني كان قد تحدث
في همم قبل زيارته الى المنطقه عن
فكره اعاده تشكيل التواجد العسكري
الامريكي في الشرق الاوسط من خلال تجميع
مظله امنيه تمتد من اسرائيل عبر الخارج هل
يمكن ان يندرج من هذا التحرك الان هذه
الفكره
من الواضح ان هذه الفكره ماتت قبل ان تولد
لانه دون المنطقه
رفض يعني وضعت خط احمر انه لا يمكن
التعاون العسكري مع اسرائيل لا يمكن
السماح لاسرائيل بالدخول في تحالف لدول
المنطقه سواء كان بامريكا او بدونها
حتى الدول حتى الدول التي وقعت يعني
اتفاقيات سلامه مع اسرائيل في الامارات
والبحرين ابدت رفضها لان لن تقبل مثل هذا
الشيء لذلك متى هذه الفكره وقد يكون هناك
محاوله لايجاد بديل يعني نوع بديل من
التعاون بحيث انه لا تكون في اسرائيل
وبنفس الوقت يمثل الضغط المطلوب لانه
امريكا تريد اعاده تواجدها في المنطقه
بدون ان تكثف وجود قواتها بالتالي هي
تحتاج الى
تعزيز جوانب معين يعني معينه من القوه لدى
حلفائها بحيث انه يكون بينهم تنسيق وتعاون
لتحقيق الاهداف المشتركه بدون تواجد عسكري
يعني بدون وجود جنود على الارض
هذه التصريحات سيد احمد اتت ايضا بعد
تقارير يعني ايضا كتبت او نشرت في بعض
الصحف الامريكيه
منسوبه الى الاستخبارات الامريكيه او
مسؤولين فيها عن تطور في العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين بين موسكو وطهران قد يصل
ربما الى استراتيجيات الدفاعيه او تحالف
دفاعي هل يمكن وضع هذا التحرك الامريكي
ايضا كخطوه استباقيه ربما مثل اللي مثل
هذا التحول في العلاقات بين بين روسيا
وايران
العلاقات العسكريه بين روسيا وايران
ليست جديده يعني ربما تزايده مؤخرا بسبب
حاجه روسيا الى ايران يعني في الماضي كانت
ايراني التي تحتاج الى روسيا عسكريه بشكل
حصري اليوم اصبحت روسيا تحتاج الى ايران
بسبب نقص الذخائر لان الحربه مع اوكرانيا
استنسفت مخزون الذخائر فاصبحت تحتاجه
تحتاج الى الصين الى ايران في تمويدها
بالذخائر فبالتالي يعني ظهرت هذه التقارير
عن ازدياد هذا التعاون لا شك لا شك ان
المخططين الاستراتيجيين في كل دول العالم
ينظرون الى كل شيء ويحاولون يعني اخذ
احتياطاتهم ربما يكون هذا
العوامل الدافعه ولكنه ليس ليس دافع
الرئيسيه ليس هو الهدف الحصري لهذه
التحركات هو ربما يكون عامل مساعد لا اكثر
في المقابل كيف يمكن تصور موقف الكونجرس
الذي يعيش ربما حاله من الفوضى اليوم كما
يراها الكثير من المراقبين في ظل الفشل
تلو الاخر في اا يعني تعيين رئيس جديد له
وهناك الكثير ربما وبعض المشرعين والنواب
الذين تحدثوا عن اجراءات انتقاميه من
المملكه العربيه السعوديه ضمن مشاريع
معينه تهدف الى منع مبيعات الاسلحه وغيرها
الغال
وهم غالبا اقصى اليسار من يخرج تصريحات
يعني همم تهاجم السعوديه او تتواعد
السعوديه حتى عندما تفعلها الاداره يعني
حتى عندما يصرح ايضا مثل هذه التصريحات هو
يفعلها فقط لاسترضاء اليسار بشكل مؤقت
دائما هذه تصريحات تظهر قبل الانتخابات
مباشره وتموت بعد الانتخابات مباشره ولكن
اقصى اليسار لا يملك الان اي سلطه في
الحقيقه بخصوصا بعد فقد اغلبيه مجلس
النواب مجلس النواب سيكون مشلوله تمام من
خلال السنتين القادمه سيشل معه الكونجرس
همم العمل الخارجي والعسكري سيكون يعني
عاده انه يكون 80 90% بيد السلطه
التنفيذيه ممثله بالرئيس الوزراء وعشره
20% بالكرس ربما خلال سنتين القادمه سيكون
100% الى السلطه التنفيذيه بعد كل ما
ذكرته سيد احمد وفضل هذه التقنيه هل نتحدث
عن منحه جديد همم
ستشهد العلاقات السعوديه الامريكيه في كل
مجالات امم في اطار يعني
شراكه في حل بعض المشكلات الاستراتيجيه
التي تواجه البلدين لانه هذه الزياره او
هذا الموقف ياتي بعد زياره قام بها الرئيس
الصيني توقيع اتفاق استراتيجي بين الرياض
وبكين علاقات ربما متقدمه مع روسيا في في
ضوء كذلك اوبيك بلاس وغيرها من المواقع
العلاقات العلاقات بين السعوديه وبين
الصين من جهه وبين السعوديه وبين الروسي
من جهه اخرى هي دائما علاقات اقتصاديه
وليست علاقات امنيه مهما قيل في هذا
الموضوع لا روسيا ولا الصين قادران على
همم يعني تعزيز امن فعلي في المنطقه
امريكا هي الوحيده القادره على ذلك لذلك
العلاقات بين السعوديه وامريكا في هذا
المجال المستمر همم تضعف وتقوى ولكنها
دائما في احد اعلى من الجيد ولكن لو
تذكرنا زياره بيض للسعوديه لم يكن التركيز
على جوانب عسكريه كانت تركيز كله على
جواله باقتصاديه
ان يتبع ذلك يعني ما حدث في زياره الرئيس
الصيني للسعوديه وتوقيع اتفاقيات
استراتيجيه يجعل الامريكيين يفكرون باننا
لم نقدم ما يكفي لن يعيد تواجدنا في
المنطقه بالقدر الذي نريده وبالتالي نحن
نحيد نحتاج لتقديم اكثر من ذلك لذلك هم
يبحثون عن ماذا يستطيعون ان يفعلونه
ليعيدوا لموضوعهم في المنطقه بشكل افضل
بالتالي لا يمكن ان تتاثر او هذه العوده
في العلاقه بهذا الشكل الذي ذكرته ان
تتاثر العلاقات بين الرياض وبكين هذا ما
فهموني
نعم يعني الصين تعلم تعلم ما تستطيع ان
تفعله مالا تستطيع ان تفعل الصين فعليا
يعني تتوسع في المنطقه بشكل اكبر بكثير
مما تع- يعني مما اا من مما يمكن ان يكون
لها يعني يتحقق نجاح كبير كل ما حققته
يعتبر نجاح كبير بالنسبه له بالتالي ان
تتوقف عند هذا الحد يعتبر بالنسبه للصين
وضع جيد جدا
فلم تحاول ان تضغط على اي احد لتقديم اي
تنازلات اضافيه بالعكس هم هم راضيين اما
حدث ومبسوطين
واذا استطاع الامريكان ان يرفع من تواجدهم
بعض الشيء هذا لا يضر الصين ولا يضر
الاتفاقيات التي وقعت معها مع كل دول
المنطقه
والسعوديه اوضحت يعني جعلت الامر الواضح
للعالم كله وخصوصا لامريكا اننا مستعد
للعمل مع الجميع ولكن لا احد يتدخل في
علاقات الخارجيه علاقاتنا مع هو مع روسيا
سواء كانت في اي مجال نحن السنن سنوسعها
وسنحسنها وسنحقق فائده اكبر منها شئتم
امام ابيتهم الامر غير قابل للنقاش وغير
قابل للتفاوض ليس ورقه تفاوض يعني يحصل
على شيء مقابلها لا هذا خارج كل شيء
والامريكيين يعرفون انهم لا يستطيعون ان
يمنعوا السعوديه من ذلك كل الضغوط التي
يمكن ان تمارسها امريكا بدون ان تتضرر
المصالحها الحيويه سبق ممارسه في فتره
سابقه ولم تاتي بنتيجه بالتالي موضوع
الضغط انتهى لم يعد من الممكن ان يمارس اي
ضغط اضافه الان وصلت العلاقات للحد الادنى
ممكن يراد تحسينها فقط والتحسين لا يتم عن
طريق الضغط يتم عن طريق تقديم تقديم اشياء
اضافيه تقديم يعني همم تحقيق مصالح اكبر
كذا وتفعل وكذا نحقق المصلحه الفنيه وليس
اذا لم تفعل شكرا
الامريكيه همم الباحث في الشهر الامريكي
احمد الحنطي شكرا لك مرتين
رابعه بعد قليل مجله عالميه تختاروا العلا
ضمن عجائب الدنيا السبع للعام الجاريه
اهلا بكم الجديد
الفنادق ومرافق الايواء باقتناء اللوحات
الخاصه بالفنانين والفنانات السعودي هذا
القرار ضمن المعايير الثقافيه الجديده
لمرافق الضيافه بهدف تعزيز واثراء التجارب
الثقافيه المختلفه ومنها الفنون التشكيريه
والتراث وفنون الطهي والاعمال الفنيه
والموسيقيه وغيرها
تنوع سياحيا ملفت تشهده الاحساء حيث
المواقع التاريخيه والاسواق الشعبيه التي
تستقبل السياح والزوار خلال موسم شتاء
السعوديه نواف عزيز
[موسيقى]
روح السعوديه اختارت الاحساء وجهه للسياح
في شتاء السعوديه لم يكن ذلك بمحض الصدفه
فالاحساء تعتبر اكبر واحد قائمه بذاتها في
العالم وتزخر بعمق تاريخي وحضاري
[موسيقى]
سوق القيصريه اولى الوجهات على دليل شتاء
السعوديه في الاحساء هنا يمكنك التعرف على
نمط الحياه التجاريه قديما في هذه المدينه
[موسيقى]
اه اه
المدرسه الاميريه في الاحساء عند زياره
هذا المكان سيعود بك الزمن لعشرات السنين
الى الوراء ستتعرف على اساليب التعليم في
السعوديه قديما وابرز الشخصيات من وزراء
وامراء الذين كانوا طلبه في هذه المدرسه
التاريخيه
دليل شتاء السعوديه يمكن السياحه من زياره
عده مواقع تراثيه وترفيهيه ضمن الدليل مثل
سوق القيصريه القائم حاليا والذي يكشف عن
نمط الحياه التجاريه في الاحساء قديما
وبالاضافه الى القصور والقلاع التاريخيه
وعيون المياه الكبريتيه لتجربه سياحه
الاستشفاء يمكن للسائح هناك التعرف على
اقدم ميناء بحري في السعوديه
وزياره اقدم مدرسه حكوميه بالبلاد مع دخول
بيت البيعه الذي شهد مبايعه اهل الاحساء
للملك عبد العزيز قبل مئه وعشره اعوام
تشكل زياره الاحساء فرصه ثمينه للخليجيين
والمقيمين في دول الخليج نظرا لقربها من
تلك الدول وقد رحبت السعوديه مؤخرا
بالمقيمين في دول الخليج العربي بعد ان
سهلت لهم اجراءات استخراج التاشيره
السياحيه من الاحساء نواف عزيز العربيه
شمال غرب السعوديه ضمن عجائب الدنيا السبع
لعام 2023
نظرا لما تختزله من تاريخ
واثار لم يكشف النقاب عن معظمها حتى اليوم
وتضم العلماء التاريخيه انسانيه يظهر من
بينها موقع الحجر الذي بنته الحضاره
النبطيه وسجل الموقع بوصفه اول موقع تراث
العالمي ضمن اللائحه منظمه اليونسكو في
السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العلاج العربيه او مفيده العربيه نادين
مرحبا بك
نادي
اليوم وابرز معالمها التي جعلت ربما هذه
المجله العالميه تجعلها ضمن عجائب الدنيا
السبع لهذا العام
اهلا بك يا خالد واهلا بمشاهدين نشره
الرابعه على قناه العربيه معكم من هنا من
العلا عندما نسال يا خالد ويسال كل شخص
فينا لماذا العلا من عجائب الدنيا السبعه
بالعاده عندما نتحدث عن عجائب الدنيا
نتحدث اما عجائب بفعل الطبيعه او بفعل
الانسان هاتان الميزتان تجتمعان هنا في
العلا عجائب بفعل الطبيعه وعجائب بفعل
الانسان لما تحمله العلا من ارث ثقافي
وارث ايضا طبيعي لشواهد حي على مره العثور
على مر التاريخ نتحدث عن 200,000 سنه الان
اخترنا لكم في نشره الرابعه من احد اهم
المعالم وهي العجائب البيولوجيه التي صنفت
في الصادق من العجائب البيولوجيه هنا في
العلا نتابع معكم مباشره في نشرته الرابعه
جبل 2000 جبل الفيل اسمه على مسمى هذا
الجبل نسمه لما يشبه الفيل او الماموث
الضخم كما نت معكم الخرطوم ايضا انف الفيل
وهذا الجسد ياتيه الزوار من كافه انحاء
العالم وايضا من كافه انحاء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ومن الخارج ليلتقط الصور
من امام هذا الجبل طبعا هذا الجبل هو بفعل
الطبيعه لم ينحته شخص لم ينحته انسان بل
حصل هذا المشهد بفعل عوامل الحت والتعريه
وبفعل عوامل الطبيعه على مر السنين اخترنا
لكم لان العلا تم تصنيفها من ضمن عجائب
الدنيا السبعه فهو بالتالي من احد اهم
المعالم التي تجعل من العلا من عجائب
الدنيا السبعه لانه كما صمم في السابق
وصنف في السابق من العجائب البيولوجيه هنا
في العلا طبعا العلالا تحتوي على عده صخور
وعده جبال وعده اماكن تصنف بفعل الطبيعه
بانها عجائب كل ما تصير خالد لمن لا لم
يظهر العلا ومن زار العلا في كل مكان في
كل جبل وكانه عجيبه بيولوجيه الى جانب
العج لو ناخذ معك جوله في المكان
نادين او الخدمه لو المصور ياخذ منك كده
لو لبنوراميه
في المكان ماجد الامريكي نتبع معكم هذه
المنطقه طبعا خالد اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن
جبل الفيل في السابق عندما زار فريق
العربيه قبل عامين تقريبا وكانت فتره
كورونا يعني لم يكن هناك حركه ناشطه من
السياح في هذه المنطقه كان جبل الفيل
عباره عن فقط جبل تاتي الناس هنا تلتقط
الصور والمشاهد لكن اليوم نلاحظ في خلال
عامين بانه هناك اختلاف كبير يعني اصبح
هناك فعاليات الى جانب هذا الجبل في حضور
كبير للمطاعم وايضا المقاهي الساعه الان
يعني تقريبا اربعه ونصف اربعه ونصف وخمسه
والناس متواجدون هنا في محيط جبل الفيل
هذا الجبل كما تتابعونه الان عائلات وايضا
زوار ياتون من كل مكان طبعا خالد ما
لمسناه ايضا هناك تواجد كبير للسياح من
كافه الاماكن هم ياتون لانهم يحبون الاثار
لانه نتحدث خالد عن العلا يعني نتحدث عن
اماكن اثريه تاريخيه يعني مثلا تقف عن جبل
عكمه وهنا تحدث عن مكتبه مفتوحه مليئه
بالنقوش وهذا ايضا عجيبه يعني انت تقف عند
هذا الجبل وترى كل النقوش الاثريه وايضا
النقوش التاريخيه وتتخيل بان شخص كان
متواجد امامك قبل ربما ملايين السنين
ونتحدث عن 200,000 عام حضارات كبيره مره
هنا اليوم تنظم الهيئه الملكيه للعلى
المزيد من المشروعات لتطوير العلا وايضا
شعارها اليوم عندما تسير في كل شوارع ترى
لنعيد للعلا وجه الحضاري اليوم تريد
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وايضا رؤيه
العلا التي اطلقها الامير محمد بن سلمان
ان تجعل العلا وجه عالميه سياحيه طبعا
نذكر خالد بانه قبل ان يتم تصنيف علا من
ضمن عجائب الدنيا السبعه تم تصنيف بلده
العلا القديمه قريه العلا من ضمن افضل
القرى السياحيه لعام 20 22 يعني كان في
ثوابق لي تمهيد هذا الاعلان الذي شهدناه
يوم امس لحظه وصولنا الى العلا بان يتم
اعلان العلى من ضمن عجائب الدنيا السبعه
يعني خلال سنتين ربما كانت الزياره الاولى
في تغطيه القمه الخليجيه
للتغير
من خلال مشاهداتك في العلا خلال سنه ثانيه
سريعه
خالد حقيقه يعني كنت عم بقول للزملاء
معانا انه فعلا بخلال عامين انا لحظات
التغير لاحظت انه قبل كانت تقتصر العلا
على مواطنها يعني كان اهل العلم متواجدين
انا هلا صرت اشعر في كل مكان في تواجد
كبير السياح حول العالم في فعاليات كثير
كبيره لجذب السياح لياتوا الى هذا المكان
نتحدث عن اكثر من منتجع نتحدث عن اكثر من
فندق يعني المكان اختلف في غضون عمايل فما
بالك في السنوات القادمه التي ستاتي من
ضمن المشاريع التي ما زالت ايضا مخطط لها
وما زالت على الجدول الزياره على تواجدك
معنا من العلماء مش مفاجاه العربيه
في الرابع بعد قليل
رابعه توفق والطبيعه الجبليه في الصحراء
حسنه في اليوم شمال غرب السعوديه
اهلا بكم من جديد تعيش عدد من المدن
السعوديه هذه الايام موجه امطار المتفاوته
الغزاله وسط التحضيرات باستمرارها حتى
الثلاثاء المقبل تشير توقعات الى هطول
امطار غزيره وتساقط من البرد على منطقه
الرياض وعلى عزال من المنطقه الشرقيه فيما
تستمر وحاله الضباب والعدام الرؤيا في
منطقتي مكه المكرمه وعدد من المدن من
الشمال
رصدت كاميرا العربيه صوره للطبيعه الجبليه
التي تتميز بها صحراء حسنه في منطقه نيوم
شمال غرب السعوديه وتظهر صوره تشكيلات
الصخريه للمرتفعات والقمم الجبليه في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
معرض اكتشف دلاين استقبال زوري يوميا في
مؤسسه بناء في الدرعيه يقام المعرض الذي
افتتح في نوفمبر الماضي على مدار
ليمنح فرصه التعرف على معالم وتصاميم
مدينه لاين وامكانتها المعماريه والهندسيه
بالاضافه الى التعرف على قطاعات نيوم
المتعدده ومناطقها المتنوعه عبر جولات
الارشاديه باللغه العربيه والانجليزيه
من معرض العين في الدرعيه ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد الحميد اهلا عبد
الواحد ايضا ما هي مشاهدتك في المعرض نسبه
الاقبال عليه ولو تاخذنا جوله ايضا فيه
اهلا وسهلا بك خالد يعني نحن في هذا
المعرض الذي
يتوافق عليه الزوار بالرغم من هطول
الامطار هنا في الرياض والدرعيه تحديدا
الا ان زوار يتوافدون الى هذا المعرض
باقسامه المختلفه كما تشاهدون في الصوره
المعرض يحتوي العديد من الاقسام المتنوعه
والمختلفه التي يشاهد من خلالها الزوار
الاشكال الهندسيه والتصاميم وحتى الصور
المنوعه في هذا المعرض خالد هذا المعرض ما
يميزه مساحته الكبيره اضافه الى اقسامه
الخمس التي من خلالها ومن خلال تنوعها في
همم المشاهده والمتابعه من خلال المراحل
همم التي تجسد همم انواع مختلفه من الصور
والاشكال الهندسيه اضافه الى طبعا كل ما
يحتويه همم كل قسم عن الاخر في القسم
الاول خالد همم نشاهد طبعا همم في هذا
القسم تحديدا ال- المرسى البحري الخفي
الذي همم يكون في همم هذا المعرض اكتشف
همم ذا لاين كما تعلم همم كل هذه همم
الاقسام تكون بشكل متدرج همم يعني همم
ومنوع من خلال تجربه الزوار للمشاهده
والمتابعه المستمره همم نشاهد هنا خالد
همم امتدادا همم المرسى الخفي كل هذه
الصور الجميله حقيقه يعني همم من الاشجار
والمجسمات التي يتم استعراضها في هذا
القسم
نعود مره اخرى خالد الى استكمال جولاتنا
في هذا المعرض الحقيقه خالد المعرض مساحه
كبيره يعني يتطلب المشي اكثر من مره حتى
نستطيع يعني استعراض الاقسام المنوعه
القسم الاخر يجسد تصاميم المعيشه من خلال
هذه الصور التي تشاهدونها يعني زي ما تشوف
خالد في زوار همم باستمرار المعرض بالرغم
انه كان سته شهور الا ان ااه بشكل يومي
زوار وصياح سواء من داخل السعوديه وخارج
السعوديه ياتون بشكل مستمر الى هذا المعرض
كذلك خالد
القسم التالي همم وهو همم قسم نباتات نيوم
يتواجد في اكثر من 224 نبته هذه النباتات
مناسبه
البيئه وكذلك
تحتوي اكثر من 19 نبته من النباتات
النادره كل هذه التفاصيل خالد التي نحاول
نستعرضها بصوره
المعرض على مساحه كبيره كما تعلم
القسم الاخير مراه ذا لاين يحتوي اكثر من
تصميم مختلف
للمجتمعات هذا هو قسم النباتات خالد كما
تشاهد يحتوي النباتات
المتنوعه التي نحاول ان نستعرضها في
الصوره كما تشاهد سواء في المنتصف او حتى
من خلال الصور همم في همم الجداريات التي
تستعرض كل نبته من هذه النباتات والتي
يعني هي 224 من النباتات طيب اضافه الى كل
هذا
هذا المعرض يستمر حتى ابريل يفتح ابوابه
بشكل يومي
القسم الاخير وصلاحه من اجمل الاقسام
واربع الاقسام همم وهو القسم الذي نستعرض
من خلاله مراه لاين 12 تصميم مختلف
لمجتمعات العين هذه التصاميم كما تشاهد
مجسمات يعني احنا بنحاول نقرب من واحد من
التصاميم هذه اللي تجسد هذا القسم الاخير
همم حاولنا خالد صراحه اننا نغطي الاقسام
بشكل
لاستعراضها بشكل سريع للمشاهدين شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه الجوله
من معرض العين في الرياض عبد الواحد شكرا
لك عبد الواحد
تشهد العراق بعد قليل تدشين بطوله كاس
الخليج الخامسه والعشرين التي تستضيفها
مدينه البصره المباراه افتتاحيه تجمع
المنتخب المضيف العراق مع نظيره العماني
فيما سيلاقي المنتخب السعودي نظره اليمني
في ثاني مباريات اليوم الاول هذه
الاستضافه للعراق تاتي بعد 44 عاما من
الانقطاع عن الاحتضان المناسبات الرياضيه
وفي اجواء من قبل البطوله على مطربون
عراقيون مطربون عراقيون يجعلوا الاجواء
قبل بطوله غاب العراق وعن تنظيمها لنحوين
اربعين عاما
40 عاما والعراقيون ينتظرون استقبال هذه
البطوله وهاهم على بعد ساعات بدء العرس
الخليجي في البصره الفيحاء
منذ شهرين والعراق يواصل استعداداته
المكثفه لاستضافه كاس الخليج جوانب خدميه
واخرى تنظيميه وكرنفالات الرياضيه في
بغداد والبصره اهل الفن ايضا دخلوا على خط
البطوله من خلال اغانيهم التي عبرت عن كرم
العراقيين وحبهم للخليجي واهله
مشى ابواحد ارض بحر
واحد فاتوا صدى واحد والعالم يسمعه لي
جلطه
ولحونه
وهنالك عمل من انتاج نقابه الفنانين
العراقيين بشكل مباشر وهو للفنان نجاح عبد
الغفور
كان له بصمه في هذه البطوله من خلال
اغنيته هلا بجيتكم هلا
هلا هلا
جياتكم هلا هلا هلا هلا هلا هلا
جايكم هلا النخل كله يحييكم شط العرب
حلاقه
جمهور
لم يستطع الوصول الى البصره او حجز
التذاكر لكنه سيدعم ويشجع وربما يتوقعوا
من الفائز بالبطوله مبكرا ما حصلت تذاكر
مع الاسف بس ان شاء الله حنكون متواجدين
ان شاء الله منطقه الكراده اتوقع ان شاء
الله المنتخب العراقي او المنتخب السعودي
واذا المنتخب السعودي اخذها في همم ما
راحت الغريب وان شاء الله ان شاء الله
ياخذ المنتخب العراقي
فنانون على مختلف الوانهم قدموا الدعم من
خلال اصواتهم والحانهم لانجاح هذه البطوله
كما وعد العراقيون بان تكون هذه النسخه
الاجمل من خلال التنظيم والجمهور وان تكون
كرنفالا خليجيا لكن هذه المره بنكهه
عراقيه
سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
قصير ربما عرفت افتتاح بطوله كاس خليجي 25
اقل من ساعتين تقريبا
يعني بالنسبه لحفل الافتتاح سيبدا بعد
دقائق قليله من الان هكذا كان مقررا اما
بالنسبه طبعا للمباريات المباراه الاولى
للمنتخب العراقي ومع نظيره العماني ستكون
في الساعه 7:00 طبعا هنا بالتوقيت
المحلي تليها طبعا مباراه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في العاشره الا ربع ستنطلق اما
بالنسبه للاجواء التي تسبق هذه المباراه
الاجواء ساحره فعلا هنا في مدينه البصره
وتحديدا في هذا الكورنيش الذي بات ملتقا
طبعا للوفود او للمشجعين طبعا الخليجيين
والعراقيين معظمه يتواجد هنا طبعا من
الكويت من المملكه العربيه السعوديه
مشجعون عمانيون بحرينيون كلهم التقيناهم
وهنا همم مسحورون طبعا بهذه الاجواء
سالناهم لماذا لا تفضلون الذهاب حتى الى
الملاعب لمشاهده حفل الاحتفال حفل
الافتتاح طبعا اكدوا ان الاجواء هنا ساحره
اكثر ولا تقل عما سيحدث طبعا في حفل
الافتتاح بالتالي الكل متاثر طبعا
بالاستقبال بالناس بالحفاوه همم ربما لم
يكن يتوقع معظم من جاءه الى البصره ان
تكون الامور بهذا الشكل لكن معظم من
سالناهم من تفاجؤوا كثيرا والعراقيين
الحفاوت الناس علاقه الناس كثير كثير
مبسوطين يعني الى درجه انا صراحه سالت كل
همم يعني الشباب اللي كانوا موجودين اللي
جاءوا من كل معظم دول الخليج طبعا العربي
همم الكل فرحانه متفاجاه صراحه بحفاوه
البصره واحنا كمان يعني تفاجئنا بالاجواء
الساحره حقيقه وما بدنا نفارق هذا المكان
اللي احنا موجودين فيه طبعا
افتتاح يعني الان كل الملعب هيكتمل هيكون
في حضور كبير يعني في المباراه وفي
المباراه
يعني الملعب يسع ااا 65000 متفرج همم نفذت
ال بطاقات طبعا الدخول قبل ربما اكثر من
شهر من انطلاق البطوله لكن الاعداد التي
اتت لمدينه البصره هي اكبر بكثيره تحدث
هنا عن اكثر من مليون شخص يتواجدون في
البصره من خارج البشره وهذا يشمل طبعا
الجمهور ويشمل ايضا عراقيون من محافظات
اخرى ايضا جاؤوا الى هنا هناك همم حضور
لافت لمحافظه الانبار هناك حضور لافد
لمحافظه صلاح الدين والموصل ربما ابناء
هذه المحافظات لم ااه فتح لهم الفرصه ان
ياتوا الى مدينه البصره لكن هذه المناسبه
حتى انها طبعا سمحت لمعظم ابناء المحافظات
الشماليه والوسطى بالحضور بالتالي
كل من سالناه وكان متفائل بالفوز لكن تبقى
المباريات وحسابات الفرق والاداء ايضا
داخل الملعب هو من سيحكم من سيفوز ويحصد
النقاط الثلاث نتمنى الموفقين بجميع
الفرقين والتمنياتنا بالتوفيق في هذه
البطوله من حيث التنظيم او من حيث النتائج
والجميع الجميع
القت المكسيكي القبض على افيدو جوزمن وهو
زعيم عصابه مخدرات مكسيكيه وابن
الامبراطور المخدرات اخو كينجوسمانا
المعروف
شبه اباه المكسيك تقبض على ابن امبراطور
المخدرات
والده حتى اصبح زعيم عصابه المخدرات
في 2019 وعرضت امريكا مكافاه قدرها خمسه
ملايين دولار مقابل معلومات عنهم لكن تمكن
او فيديو من مراوغه السلطات المكسيكيه
لمده ثلاث سنوات
في العاصمه مكسيكو سيتي
ما زالوا احرارا يقومون باعمال الشغب في
مدينه كوريا
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بالعناوي
بعد ساعات من بدل هدنه الروسيه الوحاديه
اشتباكات متقطعه في جبهات الحرب
الاوكرانيه
واشنطن لتعزيز العلاقات مع الرياض مشاريع
عسكريه جديده
مجله عالميه تختار العلا ضمن عجائب الدنيا
السبع للعام الجاريه 2023
والعراق تعود الاستضافه الاحداث الرياضيه
ساعات تفصلنا عن خليجي 25 في البصره
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]